this is my answer for everything is just
to make somebody else do it
it's sona fixes your life
[Music]
at underscore m underscore veridide says
how do you discipline your children well
they're four months so we don't really
discipline them yet but how do you
discipline your child
uh
again like i said i'm an expert so
obviously i know this
how do you discipline them
can you bribe them with candy that's bad
that's bad that's what you shouldn't do
because cause there's sugar can you
withhold stun no i don't know i don't
know
timeout
what did the super nanny do
um
again i'm an expert i have a rocker next
to me i think that you have to
you know what make somebody else do it
this is my answer for everything is just
to make somebody else do it
you're welcome
at adc dot delaby says which twin is
your favorite and why does the other one
suck
[Music]
uh i don't have a favorite of course i
don't have a favorite they're both
perfect in their own ways i mean and
they both suck in their own ways too if
i'm to be honest with you like
you know obviously they're really sweet
i love them so much i'm obsessed with
them they're really cute
but also like
charlie screams we call him the
pterodactyl and he's like sometimes he
can be a dick and then mikey
is just like lately he's going through
this thing where he's just like
so he can also be a dick sometimes i
mean i love them so much and i shouldn't
be calling my boys dicks but like do i
have a favorite no
and why does the other ones i have
reasons for why they suck but
they i don't have a favorite there's no
way i can ever have a favorite i'm
obsessed with both of them
but yeah they both kind of suck in their
own ways i'm gonna be honest like
there's always room for improvement and
i think that
hopefully
they'll improve
in some aspects
i love them so much i'm obsessed with
them
let me just reiterate that
but sometimes they suck at em manner
says what kind of crate is good for
storing twins
obviously an apple crate you just stick
them in there and put the lid on we're
good to go you're welcome
at nom nom derp
says what cries more twins are conan
conan
you're welcome
[Music]